من المجالات اللي ممكن فيها الحوسبة الكمومية تحسّن تعلم الآلة
هو ما يتعلق بدوال kernel أو
مصفوفات kernel — خلونا نستكشف إيش هي
وليش نحتاجها، وعشان نفهم هذا راح نذكّر أنفسنا بـ
ثلاث نقاط: ليش يظهر الضرب النقطي في تعلم الآلة؟
وليش مسائل تعلم الآلة تتعامل مع أبعاد عالية؟
وإيش هي دوال kernel؟
تذكّر أن الضرب النقطي أو الضرب الداخلي
لمتجهين حقيقيين n-بُعديين a
و b يساوي حاصل ضرب مقدار a
في مقدار b مضروبًا في جيب تمام الزاوية θ
بينهما، وهذا يعادل ضرب
كل مركّبة من a في المركّبة المقابلة من
b وجمعها، وانتبه — إذا كان المتجهان
شبه متعامدين، كأن يكون لـ a
مركّبات صفرية حيث مركّبات b كبيرة
فالضرب النقطي يكون صغيرًا، وهذا يعادل
اقتراب θ من π/2
وبالمثل إذا كانت مركّبات a سالبة بينما
مركّبات b موجبة
أي أن المتجهين يشيران
في اتجاهين شبه متعاكسين
وθ قريبة من π
فنتيجة الضرب النقطي يمكن أن تكون
سالبة، وأخيرًا إذا كانت مركّبات a كبيرة حيث
مركّبات b أيضًا كبيرة وبنفس الإشارة
أي أن المتجهين شبه متوازيين وθ قريبة من الصفر
فالضرب النقطي سيكون كبيرًا
وموجبًا، فمن المنطقي جدًا توقّع أن الضرب النقطي
مقياس مفيد للتشابه
بين نقاط البيانات، لكن ليس كل البيانات n-البُعدية
يسهل فصلها بقطع (n-1)-بُعدية
يعني خط أو مستوى أو hyperplane، لما تكون البيانات غير منفصلة جيدًا
في n بُعدًا، نقدر نُدمج نقاط البيانات
في أبعاد أعلى، مثلًا m بُعدًا حيث m
أكبر من n، وهذا يُسمى feature mapping
ويُرمز له عادةً بـ x تذهب إلى φ(x) حيث
φ(x) هي دالة تربط الأعداد الحقيقية n-البُعدية بـ
الأعداد الحقيقية m-البُعدية
وأسهل صورة لهذا هي
تخيّل رفع بيانات أحادية البُعد إلى
بُعدين، أو أخذ بيانات ثنائية البُعد
ودمجها في ثلاثة أبعاد
لكن في الواقع كثيرًا ما ندمج البيانات في فضاءات بآلاف
أو حتى ملايين الأبعاد
الفرق بين ضرب نقطي ثلاثي البُعد وآخر ثنائي البُعد لا يُذكر
لكن الضرب النقطي لمتجهات ذات مليون بُعد
مقارنةً بضرب نقطي ثنائي البُعد فرق ضئيل
لكن الضرب النقطي لمتجهات بمليون بُعد
يصبح شبه مستحيل
لتطبيقه على مجموعة بيانات ضخمة
فاخترع الناس حيلة ذكية
ماذا لو استخدمنا إسقاطًا
إلى أبعاد أعلى بصيغة محددة جدًا
بحيث تكون الضروب النقطية للمتجهات في
الأبعاد العالية دالة بسيطة من
المتجهات ذات الأبعاد المنخفضة؟ أي نجد دالة تربط
بياناتنا x بـ φ(x) ذات الأبعاد العالية
بحيث يكون الضرب الداخلي في
فضاء الميزات معطًى بـ
دالة بسيطة في البيانات ذات الأبعاد المنخفضة.
هذه الدالة k تُسمى دالة kernel
بشكل مثالي نريد من دالة kernel هذه
أن تكون دالة للضرب الداخلي
في الأبعاد المنخفضة نفسه، وهذا سيمنحنا
أفضل ما في الحالتين: فضاء ميزات ذو أبعاد عالية جدًا
مع ضرب داخلي سهل وسريع الحساب
للوهلة الأولى قد لا يبدو
واضحًا أن هذا ممكن أصلًا، فلنأخذ
مثالًا بسيطًا في أبعاد منخفضة جدًا
تأمّل هذا feature mapping المحدد: يربط
متجهًا ثلاثي البُعد بـ
فضاء تسعة أبعاد، واتضح
أن الضرب الداخلي في فضاء الميزات التسعي الأبعاد
يساوي ببساطة الضرب الداخلي في الفضاء الأصلي
ثلاثي الأبعاد مرفوعًا للمربع، فالضرب الداخلي
في الفضاء المُحوَّل باستخدام دوال φ
يتطلب حساب كل مركّبة من
الإحداثيات التسعة للـ
متجه الأول وتسعة للـ
متجه الثاني، ثم الضرب الداخلي نفسه وهو
تسعة ضروب إضافية وجمع
المجموع الكلي ثمانية وعشرون عملية
أما دالة kernel فتحتاج ثلاثة ضروب فقط
وجمعين، أي أربع عمليات فحسب
وهذا كان لربط نقطة بيانات ثلاثية الأبعاد بـ
فضاء ميزات تسعي الأبعاد
من السهل أن نرى كم سيكون هذا مفيدًا جدًا
للفضاءات الكبيرة جدًا.
دالة kernel عادةً هي دالة مستمرة
يمكن تطبيقها على أي متجه في مجموعة بياناتك
لكننا نستخدم دوال kernel بأخذ
أزواج من نقاط البيانات في مجموعتنا
كمُدخلات، وتطبيق دالة kernel على
كل زوج من نقاط البيانات في المجموعة
ينتج عنه مصفوفة متماثلة تُسمى مصفوفة kernel
نوع دالة kernel التي ستستخدمها يعتمد على
مشكلتك، وخلاصة القول:
وصف التشابه بين المتجهات في مجموعات بياناتنا
كثيرًا ما يحتاج ضروبًا داخلية، والضروب الداخلية في
فضاءات الميزات ذات الأبعاد العالية جدًا تصبح مُكلفة
فنلجأ إلى feature mappings المقابلة
لدوال kernel خاصة بعينها
تجعل الحساب أكثر كفاءة
لكن هذا التقييد على دوال kernel الخاصة
يُقيّد أيضًا أنواع التحويلات إلى فضاء الميزات التي يمكن
إجراؤها بكفاءة، وهذا
قد يمنعنا من فصل بياناتنا بشكل جيد
يا ريت لو كان في طريقة أخرى!
وهنا يأتي دور الحوسبة الكمومية
الـ feature mapping ذو الأبعاد العالية جدًا المقابل
لدوال kernel يمكن تنفيذه
على حاسوب كمومي في quantum kernel estimator
تُحسب مصفوفة kernel k
ومن هناك يمكن استخدام خوارزمية تعلم آلة كلاسيكية
لإنجاز هذا، تُحمَّل نقطة بيانات x1
وتُحوَّل، ثم تُحمَّل
نقطة أخرى x2
وتُحوَّل، ولأن الضرب الداخلي لحالتين كموميتين
يرتبط باحتمالية القياس
نستطيع تقدير الضرب الداخلي للنقطتين المُحوَّلتين
بإجراء قياسات كافية على
الـ circuit الناتج، وبهذه الطريقة يستطيع circuit
إخبارنا عن ضرب داخلي
في أي فضاء ذي أبعاد عالية يستطيع الـ circuit نمذجته
دون أن نحسب كلاسيكيًا أي ضرب داخلي أو
دالة kernel، وهناك طرق كثيرة
لتخصيص وتحسين هذه الأساليب
وبالفعل هناك دائمًا أساليب جديدة تُقترح
وتُختبر، نأمل أن هذه
النظرة العامة تكون قد أفادتك في فهم
تطبيق الحوسبة الكمومية
في أساليب تعلم الآلة
وخاصة تلك التي تتعلق بـ kernels